um before you go can you share uh just
the the most interesting Gaga story you
had with her maybe maybe it was early on
maybe it was when she I don't know wore
a meat dress to the day I don't know
just give me like a crazy Gaga story you
haven't shared yet I think the probably
the crazy Gaga stories when we went to
San Francisco to push a record for the
first time and I remember we went to
this radio station and I was in the
radio artist I mean the radio DJ kept
asking me
um about what I got going on and I was
like yo you know
it's my new artist guy you know we
pushing it and they were like yeah yeah
but but what do you got like yeah at the
time she's a new artist I'm like hold up
I'm here you ain't going nowhere but I
need the world to understand that this
girl right here is gonna be the biggest
artist in the world right and he had
this look on his face like
whatever wow but the beautiful part
about it was that he said the only way
that I could see that happening is if
obviously if she caters to the you know
um uh the gay community basically yeah
and so he was like so
speaking of you
what do you prefer
guys or girls
he asked her that yeah and right before
she can open him up I was like both
and she was like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
roach are you serious I guess she's very
curious she's colorful
I know she probably wanted to kill me at
that moment but at the same time she
kind of I think she knew exactly what I
was saying and they just they kind of
elaborated on her and she had the best
answer and she was like yeah well you
know I I just I'm I'm just a free spirit
and the guy was like see we can rock
with you what's the plan and they played
her record
I mean and it's in San Francisco yes
yeah moment they played her record it
became number one on phones the same day
wow that's huge it was like I mean she's
an icon period but also an icon in that
Community right no no she but then it
was interesting because as her career
developed
that became one of her biggest like
movements is oh yeah they love that yeah
shout out shout out to the uh yeah the
the yeah